Have you ever wondered why some people
are lactose intolerant? It's because
their bodies no longer make enough of
an enzyme called lactase, which helps
break down the sugar lactose into
smaller sugars that the body can use.
Enzymes are proteins that speed up all
kinds of different chemical reactions
in the body.
Some enzymes, like lactase, help break
things apart, while other enzymes help
put things together.
Let's take a closer look at the
chemical reaction that turns the big
sugar, lactose, into the smaller sugars,
glucose and galactose.
The addition of water breaks the bond
in the middle of the lactose molecule
with a chemical reaction called
hydrolysis.
But the lactose molecule needs to be in
just the right position when it
encounters the water in order for the
reaction to work. That's where our
enzyme lactase can help. Lactose binds
to a special part of the enzyme called
the active site. We call lactose the
substrate of the enzyme lactase because
it fits into the enzyme's active site,
like a key fits into a lock. Only a key
of the right shape and the right
electric charge will fit. The active
site of the enzyme holds lactose in
just the right position to allow water
to come break the bond. Once the
reaction is complete, the enzyme
releases the products of the reaction,
glucose and galactose. Now, the lactase
can find another lactose molecule and
start the process all over again.
Lactase made the chemical reaction
happen faster by holding lactose in
just the right position. When it's
working at full speed, it can split up
to 60 lactose molecules per second.
People who are lactose intolerant can
actually swallow some lactase before
they drink milk to allow them to break
it down. Thanks to enzymes, all the
chemical reactions in our bodies can
happen much faster.